in this video I want to introduce the
idea of cell signaling so what is cell
signaling well it's basically the idea
behind how extracellular signals which
are signals that come from the outside
of the cell things like hormones how
they could trigger a cellular response
so if something comes from the outside
of the cell comes over to a cell causes
that cell to respond in a certain way so
the type of extracellular signals that
we're going to be concerned with our
hormones so what is a hormone a hormone
first and foremost is an intercellular
messenger they travel between cells
more specifically the hormones are
released from a ductless gland excuse me
sorry about that a ductless gland so
this part of the definition is really
not too important for our sake but it is
specific to the definition of al-ahmad
another aspect of hormones is that a
trap transported in blood in the blood
from an endocrine cell in one portion of
the body to a target cell somewhere else
in the body usually far away and that
target cell has a receptor that is
specific to that hormone find that
hormones are very specific as far as
what they bind to so now where is this
receptor the cell has a receptor or
where is that receptor well the answer
to that question in order to answer it
we have to think about what hormone is
actually coming over to bind we have to
think about what is the class of that
hormone it depends on the class of that
hormone so there are three classes or
three types of hormones steroid hormones
peptide or polypeptide hormones and
amino acid derivatives now what we're
going to be basically concerned with is
whether this class is polar or nonpolar
in the case of steroids
they are nonpolar steroid hormones on
nonpolar some examples of steroid
hormones are the sex steroids estrogen
and testosterone the second class
peptide or poly peptide um
hormones are just basically like protein
hormones or sequences of amino acids and
generally speaking these are polar
hormones so examples that we're actually
going to talk about our insulin and
glucagon third class is amino acid
derivatives and these are usually also
polar and it depends on obviously the
amino acid to derive from an epinephrine
it's an example of that also known as
adrenaline so now why did I mention that
why do we care whether these are
nonpolar or polar the reason why is
because knowing that information will
tell you where the receptor for that
hormone will be if something is nonpolar
then it can diffuse across a plasma
membrane so the receptors for steroids
the receptors for steroids will be
inside of the cell because the steroids
being that there are nonpolar they can
just diffuse from the outside of the
cell into the inside but peptide or
polypeptide hormones or amino acid
derivatives that are polar
they won't travel through that
hydrophobic space that in the plasma
membrane so these guys their receptors
are on the outside of the cell they're
on the cell surface so that's an
important thing to keep in mind so what
actually happens when that hormone binds
the receptor receptor so this thing
called a signaling cascade occurs which
is basically a signaling cascades
basically just a series of steps caused
by a hormone binding event so hormone
bind the receptor it causes a series of
steps to occur so those series of steps
they can do different things they can
either alter enzyme activity so there
are enzymes in our cells right so they
can make them more or less active or
inhibit or activate them that could
change what's going on in our cells
another thing that these signal Cascades
can do is they can alter gene
transcription so if we have
a that can be turned into RNA we might
do more or less gene transcription of a
particular gene if a certain hormone
causes that excuse me
so this brings us to this idea of signal
transduction and I've written out the
definition here it says the process by
which an extracellular signal is
converted and amplified into a cellular
response okay that's all kinds of fancy
terms whatever the whole idea is that is
that something from outside of the cell
comes to a cell and triggers a response
in that cell that's what signal
transduction is so signal transduction
usually involves this thing called a
second messenger so the first thing that
comes to my mind when when someone tells
me that this process involves a second
messenger is well there's got to be a
first messenger right you can't have a
second one if it's not first one and
that is the case right the first
messenger is the actual hormone right or
whatever that extracellular signal is
the hormone that's coming to bind the
cell initially or bind the receptor for
that buying the cells receptor that's
the first messenger so in our case we're
talking about hormones being those
initial first messengers those things
initially arrive to the target cell
those are the first messengers now the
second messengers were those things
those are molecules that are made inside
the cell and they're made in response to
the first messenger so here a molecule
made inside the cell in response to the
hormone binding event at least in our
case now why is that
significant usually these second
messengers they have some sort of impact
on the active activity of the cell right
as far as what we mentioned up here we
mentioned that could alter enzyme
activity or alter gene expression now
they're usually created in high or large
amounts and that's significant and the
reason why is because we think about the
second messengers being created after
one hormone binding event so one hormone
binds and then many many many second
messengers are created so these many
second messengers can go on and go on
and activate or deactivate certain
things in the cell and because many
second messengers are made because
they're made in higher large amounts
they can amplify the signal essentially
one hormone binding event can trigger a
great response because the second
messengers amplify that signal I hope
that was a good brief introduction to
cell signaling we'll talk about more
details in the future
one last thing I'm a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email I move University
at gmail.com and see the description
below for more details thank you for
watching